[Musique]
nouvelle tendance on nous offre
maintenant une assurance pour des
billets de spectacle selon des experts
que nous avons consulté les assureurs
ont développé ce produit en réponse à la
pandémie de covid-19 ce qui est assez
ironique parce que c'est protections ne
couvrent pas les annulations dues à une
épidémie ou une pandémie mais si vous
vous blessez grièvement vous serez
remboursé dans la mesure où vous le
trouvez document à l'appui l'assurance
vous remboursera aussi si vous êtes
retenu comme juré dans un procès en cas
de maladie grave si vous avez perdu
votre emploi ou même en cas de panne
mécanique par contre le prix varie
beaucoup d'inspecteur à l'autre pour le
concert de Metallica cela représente 2%
du prix du billet mais pour le groupe
Montréal est Moon Run on parle de
presque 30% du coût d'un billet
rappelez-vous ce produit n'est pas
obligatoire au Québec et en Ontario vous
avez 10 jours après l'achat pour annuler
cette assurance mais attention si vous
êtes au Nouveau-Brunswick vous ne pouvez
pas l'annuler
facilement
[Musique]